-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Okay.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden visited
a 70-year-old bridge
in Lake Charles, Louisiana
today while pitching
his jobs and infrastructure plan
because if Biden's
proof of anything,
it's how much good
a few thousand dollars
in bridge work can do for you.
President Biden
went to a Mexican restaurant
in Washington yesterday
in honor of Cinco de Mayo.
He had the enchiladas
and Major had the mariachi band.
[ Laughter ]
Senate minority leader
Mitch McConnell said yesterday
that, "100% of my focus
is on stopping
the Biden administration."
Oh, really? I don't remember
seeing you there.
Put your money
where your mouth is, bud.
Also, where is your mouth?
Allies of Rudy Giuliani
have reportedly asked
former President Trump
to pay Giuliani
for representing him
through the 2020 election.
Um, do they know
what kind of job he did?
That's like the captain
of the Titanic asking,
"So, where do I
submit my invoice?"
A woman was recently arreste
at the Atlanta airport
after officials discovered
3 pounds of cocaine
hidden in the bottom
of seven pairs of shoes.
In her defense, 3 pounds
of cocaine is the only way
to make your connection
at that airport.
The fitness company Peloto
recalled two of its treadmills
yesterday after dozens
of injuries
involving children
were reported.
That's crazy. Who can afford
a Peloton and children?
A woman in Missouri
recently discovered
a World War II-era Japanese bomb
while gardening,
which came as a surprise because
she planted cruise missiles.
[ Laughter ]
Employees of a coronavirus
testing facility
at an Indonesian airport
were arrested yesterday
for allegedly washing
and re-using
nasal swabs for passengers
Well, at least
they know who's got COVID now.
Looks like, uh, yeah...
everyone.
And finally, Mother's Day
is this weekend,
according to six voicemail
from your mother.
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.